este proceso para elegir el reemplazo
boris johnson va mucho más rápido de lo
que incluso se creía los eliminados son
el actual ministro de finanzas nadie
zawawi que ha sido nombrado hace apenas
unos días cuando inició todo este
apocalipsis todo este terremoto político
y también también ha sido eliminado
jeremy hunt que fue finalista en el 2019
como boris johnson quedan seis
candidatos entonces en esta carrera
reach es un experimento que me va de
listas que es la actual ministra de
exteriores fue la wta berman y tortuga
en hand la más reciente encuesta de
yougov que fue divulgada hace apenas
unas horas da como la gran favorita no
solamente de los diputados sino de las
bases conservadoras a penny marshall que
se convirtió en la primera ministra de
defensa británica en la historia también
es bien importante resaltar que estas
son apenas encuestas pero es importante
revisar los resultados de las últimas
horas risas una que tuvo 88 votos
panismo dan 67 listas 50 y que me valen
40 luisa como es que se lleva a cabo
este proceso y como seguirá este proceso
electoral
estamos en la etapa en que los diputados
conservadores que tienen una silla en el
parlamento británico están eligiendo y
eliminando candidatos para hasta que
queden dos así que este jueves y
posiblemente el viernes habrá una nueva
ronda de eliminación el candidato que no
obtenga 30 votos saldrá de la carrera
hasta que queden 2 entonces estas
personas estos dos elegidos iniciarán
una gira por todo el reino unido para
presentar su programa de gobierno a las
bases conservadores entonces luego estas
bases unas 180.000 personas tendrán que
votar por su candidato pronto lo tendrán
que hacer en agosto probablemente y
entonces el nuevo primer ministro la
nueva primera ministra será anunciada el
5 de septiembre
boris johnson según un vocero de downing
street- estará en el gobierno hasta el 6
de septiembre ese mismo día el nuevo
primer ministro la nueva primera
ministra se reunirá con la reina isabel
que es la jefa de estado de este país
entonces iniciará un nuevo gobierno
conservador